okay and
i noticed lynn's got a good picture of
the the sea behind you in dawlishlyn i
don't see any coast guard helicopters or
any uh
yachts that shouldn't be in the area uh
coming up in your area at the moment
i can't hear you lynn
i can't hear lynn can you heal him
counselors we're live on youtube now
okay
i realize that i just i can't hear lynn
councillor goodman bradbury we can't
hear your audio at the moment
can you hear me now yeah yeah okay um
we're live so we'll make a start um
welcome to the last audit scrutiny
committee of 2020
hooray we've got there um
it's a quiet morning there's uh four of
us were just quara this morning
uh four members um and we've had
apologies from hugh cox have we had
apologies from anybody else
um apologies from councillors
um rolison
cox kolcloff and malone
okay okay well down to 50
that's all right we can do that um
okay minutes of the meeting of
uh 21st of october um
i'm happy to propose those as a true and
correct record
uh uh do i have a secondary
yeah i'm happy to second thank you do we
have any issues arising from those that
we
no i'm fine okay thank you
uh any declarations of interest
no just a shake of head chris no
no no i've been informed of okay thank
you
um any public questions
no chair no any member questions
okay so they'll say the last um
everyone else will forecast i think i
invited lots of people to come and join
us where are they
anyway short and sweet um
okay uh item number six on the agenda is
the review
of the contract procedure rules and i
believe
that's rosanna
is that your report yeah that is me
thank you
thank you um thank you for having me
today
um i'm just going to bring up my screen
so i can see what i've written
um okay so this is the review of the
contract procedurals um
and the last time they were reviewed
were in 2015
um i've i've stated the main
changes and such as
purchases under 10 000 pounds consider
local suppliers in the first instance um
we've added um continued
continuity and compatibility as a as a
not as a separate item to the waiver but
just as an addition to limited markets
um and i think the main change that i
need to discuss today
is the uh the increase in the thresholds
um so the old 2015 thresholds were
um seven and a half thousand to fifty
thousand is a request for quotation via
the portal
and then fifty thousand upwards as a
tender now
i have separated these out into goods
and services and then separately work
sorry uh it separately works i do
apologize
okay that's fine my cat joined us
in the dartmouth national park meeting
yesterday so
yeah my dog cares about contract
procedurals at team british district
council so um
um we've got uh
ten so we've we've split it into goods
and services and then
works and then we have um uh
10 000 upwards uh to 50 000 would be an
rfq for goods and services
and then we have um again 50 000
upwards is the tender so that hasn't
changed however with works
we've got up to fifteen thousand so
fifteen thousand to a hundred thousand
would be
the rfq the request for quotation and
then a hundred thousand upwards would be
the tender
um and the the reason why i've done this
is because it's in line with
generally what um the uh
the public contracts regulations of 2015
um
use for for their uh practices
because it's um 181 000 for goods and
services and 4.5 million for works in
order to follow the eu
processes now i know you know we're
going to be leaving the european market
but
um but that's generally the the
line of action i went against and then
um
the the contract procedure regulations
of 2015
will still be used with the new
find a tender service that we're going
to be using post brexit so the
regulations are still
the same um and
the how i came up with these um
thresholds uh is generally by
um doing a a nationwide um
research of contract procedure rules uh
around the uk from various councils
local authorities
um and and this this is uh what i
um i have produced i've liaised with the
procurement champions
uh across all all three of my councils
and um and they're all in agreement
um that there was um uh
there was a comment to say that if we're
we are increasing
the the works value to 100 000 then uh
we need to state in there that um
officers need to use um you know various
suppliers they they can't stick with the
same contractor every time so so we've
added that in there as well
um and in general the general layout of
the contract procedure rules has
changed um and just a
a pre warning that you know they may be
tweaked again
and because of the uh
the the leaving the european market but
um at the moment we're just in
consultation period
regarding the the regulations and
it's how long's a piece of string as to
you know when these new regulations will
come out so
my thoughts were let's let's get it
changed now
let's let's review it now rather than
waiting longer
um and then we'll just review it again
when when we can um
so that is um generally uh
the the update of the contract procedure
rules i've also
attached the track changes document in
there um so if you do have any questions
please let me know
okay thank you um yeah because my
question was going to be where did the
figures come from and
you said you've already done the
research this is sort of best practice
for other councils and local authorities
yeah and i can you know i there's
there's reams of notes that i can show
you if you wish to see them
yeah um okay do we have any questions
bill yeah i was just um
thinking about you've got a procedure
now that's geared for
um current ec membership um
will you be caught for breaking the
rules if in fact you don't go to europe
i know the common sense of it is
when we're out um
what i'm trying to say is that the rules
seem to direct you towards europe at the
moment
and you won't be altering it on the
first of january i guess but
um does the common sense prevail at the
end of the day
so um the these contract procedure
regulations um
aren't in place of of the um
the public contracts regulations which
is the
eu element um these these are
what we follow for anything under the eu
threshold
within the council um when we exit the
eu
the only thing that will change for the
moment
is where we advertise um so these
contract procedure rules
won't come in until at least january and
and within that we've we've got you know
we've removed the eu elements
um and and put that we won't be
advertising to the eu market but we'll
be advertising to the new national find
a tender service which
is all set up it's running and all we've
got to do
well all the third party who is dealing
with it for us has to do is press a
button
um so in answer to your question these
are not going to be put out before the
1st of january
but when they are um it's still in line
with
the the regulations that we have that we
follow
and the the difference being that we
won't be advertising to the european
market
that's common sense probably i should
have a little bit more no no no
no human is very complex
yeah absolutely i went on and had a look
at the find a tender service on the on
the government website
and um it's quite interesting it's
clearly been running for some time for
some people already
quite a few vendors that have gone and
passed already so
let's see us hope the government website
doesn't crash as it seems to do
regularly
about the situation with the waivers and
that in as much that we do send
tend to use quite a few waivers um
it's um know and i i
i just wonder whether you know we we
we need to sort of just keep well i know
we obviously keep a very close
look at uh waivers that are can we can
we come to that
that's on that's item nine can we come
to that i know we got something yeah
that's true
all right brilliant thank you yeah sure
all right chris yeah i do like the idea
of going from seven and a half to ten
uh thousand pounds on these small
contracts as
towns and parishes are going to be asked
by team bridge to do
more and more uh i've had one very
successful incident
with team bridge recently over the flood
lighting of the nest
i guess we were able to go quickly to
our one contractor
in this particular instance
and we've got a quote for him to come up
with new led lights and what have you
of which uh private benefactors uh
um putting up the money as it turned out
but
had we had to go and sort of go to three
different contractors
because it could have turned out be
somewhere between seven and a half and
ten thousand
it would have slowed the whole process
up and what have you i guess we've used
the same electrician
who knows where all the electoral boxes
are and is able to look at this
the the the the job priced it up quickly
i mean we we're getting it come out of
the figure
that it was but uh had it been shall we
say
somewhere between seven and a half and
ten thousand which it could have been
quite easily
this has sped the whole process up um
i would suggest i know it was probably
done under the old system don't get me
wrong but
i'm trying to make the point uh i like
the idea um
of going to this slightly higher figure
thank you yeah
um i'm gonna say probably guess it makes
sense because of the cost of raw
materials that have shot up
over the last few years um it makes
sense otherwise we'll be
you know it just makes it more difficult
doesn't it um
okay let's have a look
uh is there anybody else who has a
question or a comment
i was only going to agree really with
what's already been said by members and
that was um
i it just makes it's absolutely it makes
sense i've read the report it's
it's exactly what it says on the tin and
yeah it's good
okay sue did you want to come in
sorry
sorry um yeah rosie just out of interest
are the other authorities that you work
with also increasing their limits
are you are they keeping them in line or
are we going
um their limits are uh generally high
anyway
um so for for i mean there are some
councils some some smaller councils may
have
lower limits so for example i think
torridge is off the top of my head 5 000
but please don't quote me on that but i
know that
you know um another authority uh they go
to the full odu value before they go to
tender so that's a hundred and eighty
one thousand
um so so there are generally they are
quite high but
i i can you know i'm in contact with all
the all the procurement officers from
the southwest so
um i can ask the question about because
everyone will be reviewing their
contract procedure rules anyway in line
with what's happening with the eu
um so that will be a useful question
that i can ask yeah i thought it would
make your job easier if the
authorities you worked with are all on
the same limits
yes yeah and and it's just a point to
say
um that uh um
well definitely yes southampton and west
evan i'm gonna be taking this report to
them as well so they'll be on the same
limit
um but um it's also worth pointing
out that yes by all means i've i've
increased these limits because
i don't want to happen exactly what
counselor
clarence has has stated you know um if
we if we've got a
path refurbishment for example for seven
thousand eight hundred you know it's
much quicker to to get someone in but i
do
want to just stress that you know if you
do
know of a couple of contractors or a
couple of suppliers then please do
email both of them just to see whether
you are getting the best value for money
still
um just uh i just wanted to stress that
as well
thank you thank you okay colleagues uh
the recommendation is that we recommend
to council that the revision of the
contract procedure rules replaces the
2015 contract procedure rules
um i'm happy to propose that um i'll
second it
thank you chris are we all in favor i
think we can raise our hands don't do we
need to roll call we can see or see each
other thank you
so thank you that's carrie thank you
very much thank you
thank you i think i'll be staying on
just to hear the uh item nine
um okay yeah yeah that makes sense yeah
perfect
okay item seven strategic and corporate
risk report
okay good good morning everybody good
morning how are you
hi thank you so this is the half yearly
risk overview report
so uh to update you since the last
report which was in august
uh we've had an audit of our risk
management procedures and that
has come out with a good assurance
rating um
have as we all know kobe continues to
impact what we do
so another area we've worked on is we've
put together a new risk
st47 the impacts of kovid 19 on service
delivery and resourcing
this covers all many aspects of well
it's cross-cutting across the whole
council all aspects
of our work that are impacted by covid
uh with 19 mitigations
um that is included within the risk
register now and reviewed on a
monthly basis as it's been set at a very
high level
risk the other change that has happened
last time in here was the fact that um
risk st
43 was failure to adopt local plans the
gesp plan and t bridge plan however
as we know that that is no longer going
forward so
that has now been changed to failure to
adopt the teambridge local plan
um and we have a note here from the
officer in charge because the local plan
is regret
now progressing as the sole statutory
development plan for district
district so
overall we've got a risk matrix on page
13
uh which consists of 26 26 risks in our
risk we're just
sorry 26 and strategic risk register and
38 in the corporate
and 12 and corporate of those we've got
two that are very high
these are the same that were reported as
very high last time
the failure to control finances
and economic uncertainty
and then we've got the eight risks in
the red zone
here as well the other risks are medium
or low
in terms of risk reviews these continue
based on the
unmitigated risk status so a very high
risk we'll have a monthly view
review and the high risks will have a
quarterly review
okay the risk reports
um i've also got
um i seem to have lost my page on
oh it's further down i was going to do
project risk first but i'll go into the
risk
mitigations first so out of the risks
that we've got today the
uh one that's ones that are very high
we've got some notes
on page 14 and 15 concerning
the failure to control and manage
finance
um obviously we're doing lots of extra
monitoring on that monthly monitoring
uh looking at the government funding and
guidance from government etc and making
sure that we
we use all of the financial assistance
we can from government
to help us through difficult times
economic uncertainty i think we're all
aware of the impact on our economy
and that is still continuing again
regular updates provided to management
team and members on that
the next one down we've got five uh
mitigations with action needed
in for this four risks the first one is
in a poorly managed election sp 20
this is the risk management workshop the
notes
tell us that we're still waiting for
guidance from government on how to run
elections
during the cover pandemic and have to
report we are still waiting for that
guidance
though work has started in looking at
the risks around that and working with
officers across the council so
as soon as soon as we get that guidance
there'll be some more work on the risk
side risk
management side of running the election
next may
st 21 data quality
again there's a new post being
advertised
this time i believe successfully so this
hopefully this mitigation this action
will be able to take
take forward now to actually review the
data quality policy and start raising
well re-raising staff awareness of data
quality across the council
the next one down is a failure of ict
infrastructure
again this was noted last time the
strata business plan being approved
annually
a draft business plan has been received
so this is currently being
reviewed sp 46
uh fail of ic security measures and
cyber attacks
um there are a couple of mitigations in
this last time one of which
was to do is this cyber security
training which has now been rolled out
and the other one is the mobile device
lateral working policy
which is um i believe still in progress
section six lists out uh our key
projects across the council
uh a brief description who's responsible
and what the status of their current
risk registers are
there is the project in there the
leisure center refurbishment which is
currently on hold
not surprisingly due to covert and
resourcing issues
appendix a provides you with a full list
of the the risks in our corporate and
strategic
risk registers uh ordered by status so
you can see us glance which ones are the
very high
high medium and low
thank you chair that's that's the end of
my overview
thank you
okay well well done it's not easy it's a
bit like trying to have a crystal ball
at the moment isn't it i mean
must be i haven't seen quite so much red
but it's it's
what what can we do about it a lot of it
is very much out of our control and
um we're basically in in the hands of
what happens
else elsewhere um but um
no thank you for that uh does anybody
have any comments or questions
hey i are you still there can you hear
me
i can hear you i'll see you chris yeah
yeah no it's all right because i i have
to go to the
you know to turn the page over to look
at the you know go out of
this to look at the actual documents you
follow me that's that's the reason you
can't see me
yeah i was i was looking at st 37
with the risk on that one with um action
needed on to do with a strata business
plan
um i presume what you mean by that
is is that action has taken place if
they've done a business plan what have
you um am i correct there in asking that
to
liz
um yes there's an ongoing action plan
this is a
plan forward-looking plan rather than
the ongoing action plan i believe and
perhaps
who could uh comment on that as well
please
yes certainly it's um with slt and the
irb to look at at the moment and slt
are specifically working with strata on
what value for money indicators they
want to see
which i know you're very keen on chris
so um
that's a work in progress at the moment
and just bear in mind it's a business
plan that's got to be signed off by
all three authorities as well but it's
it's definitely in progress at the
moment
um with slt and strata of working on it
together
so how does it it's it's a i mean you
you're calling for action
so you're you're telling me the action
is needed what you
have just said is is that what you
you're getting at
the action needed it is the the the is
what's being done
which you've just described is that
correct yes that's correct
yes the way the spa system works um you
can record an
action that's ongoing something that you
do all the time to mitigate a risk
or an action that's needed that might be
outstanding or
or to be done um so until that action is
actually completed
um it will stay as a red action needed
but this action is
definitely in progress but we just don't
have a button on spa to say
in progress i think that's right liz
yeah that's what that's where i was
coming from
i was highly amused in st 20 poorly
managed
election uh in a risk assessment we're
actually telling the government to get a
move on here
and tell us how they propose to run the
election in a conventional way i
highly amuse me that cheers
[Laughter]
okay um thank you have you got any more
questions
no a bit of a bit of a sobering report
that one but thank you very much for
your work on that liz that's um it's
much appreciated sue did you want to say
something
um it was only off the back of this i
could actually mention the dojo cyber
security training um
that's one of the mitigations for the um
cyber risk and we've had real success
rolling this out to staff
it's little bite-sized chunks of cyber
awareness training
that can help you not only at work but
or as a member but also as in your
private use of the internet as well
so having rolled it out to staff we're
now ready to roll it out to members as
well so it's something
you can just access through a wedding on
your ipads and we'll put some briefing
in the members newsletter about it
and i highly recommend it because it's a
great
um company they're just bite-sized
little chunks and really
easy to um watch and educate yourself on
how to just avoid scams and email
hacking
and so forth and yeah highly recommend
so coming to a members newsletter
um well this or next week so just look
out for that one and
i can yeah it's quite good fun yeah
thank you i think i think that's going
to be um very very useful
and very much taken up because you know
the more we're relying on it the more
i'm i'm noticing
so many more scams the sharks really are
out there so
that will be extremely useful um yeah
thank you
thank you okay um our recommendation on
that sorry i could do what you have
chris i've got my ipad on one side and
my laptop that i'm looking into and i've
got to keep scrolling up and down for
the
the agenda items um uh
the recommendation on that was just to
note the report
um uh and that's it and the action's
being taken
um are we happy to do that yeah i'll
propose that
yeah okay thank you thank you very much
okay item eight is oh sorry thank you
liz thank you
very much for that um is the internal
audit
thank you chad um so quite a brief
report just to outline what we've been
doing
and it's grants grants and more grants
at the moment
um as they come in thick and fast um so
paragraph 2.2 just shows the complete
audit plan and how much we've done how
much we've got
left to do um and as you can see the
the you know the latest grants we're
working on um the local restrictions
grant open
and the additional restrictions grant
and of course we've got the wet pubs
grant just about to be launched
as well so we've we've been
objectives when we get involved with
these just to mitigate three risks or to
give assurance that three risks are
mitigated
one is that the grants are not delivered
in line with the government guidelines
two is that payments are awarded to
ineligible applicants
and three is to ensure there's no data
protection breach and that we're
processing the data securely and that's
quite important given some of the backup
documents that um
applicants have to submit um and we're
also using a third company for
some of the um discretionary um awards
so
we're just in the process of vetting
that their procedures are secure as well
um so that's basically our objectives
when we go in to audit the grants and
and also to do it in a more helpful way
rather than
obviously getting in the way of the
process of getting them rolled out
quickly so
i think that's been really valuable to
both sides
um but we really must in the new
year it'll be quarter four our final
quarter we've got to
move on to the core financial systems
work because as you can see there's some
major systems there
that we need to look at and the external
audit will be
also expecting us to have done so um not
that's just the only reason for doing
them
um so we will be moving on to some core
systems work in the new year
and yet findings have been good
and happy to take any questions i should
also mention as well the national fraud
initiative
um i'm the key contact for that and
we're just in the process of
uploading all our data for this year and
that's the national cabinet office
exercise which matches data across
all councils and lots of other bodies
including some private sector ones
to try and detect fraud and error mainly
in the benefits system
council tax support council tax discount
and so forth
so that those matches will be ready in
january and
they do usually result in a number of um
savings being made um so that's it in a
nutshell
and happy to take any questions um
i mean i just want to sort of give you
my thanks really because not you know
not only have you had
the normal things that you've had to do
every year you've had also the the
additional
um coronavirus hardship fund and the
isolation grants and
and everything else on top of that so
you know well done and thank you for
that and also i want to mention about
the coronavirus hardship fund
um about how good a response um there's
been and i know a number of businesses
have mentioned how quickly they've
received the money that's
basically kept them afloat um so
yeah thank you um well done for that
it's it's um it's really excellent work
thank you so you must be it must be
exhausted
um well i'd i just like to pass that on
to the staff that are actually
um you know generating these skills
including strata as well they really
have
excelled themselves all everybody
involved just
yeah i've gone above and beyond the call
of duty on this and i'm really proud of
them to be honest uh
so yes so it's fantastic you know we we
talk about the
the frontline work is fantastic but
there's also so many people behind the
scenes making things happen
and having to deal with arrangements at
home and
technology and and what have you so it's
yeah it's much appreciated
does anybody else have anything to ask
sue or to say
on this just want to say here here to
what you just said i must admit but um
i've got any questions
yeah no it's um it's really good keep up
the good work
and um well done uh i think
yeah our recommendation is is to just
know this report
as well but uh thank you very much thank
you
um item nine nice uh chair sorry are you
happy with just getting a proposal in a
second
yeah yeah i'll just focus rather second
yeah they're fighting over it yeah
that's fine either one
that's great either one thank you we're
all happy with that yeah yeah
thank you thank you very much okay um
final item on the agenda the financial
instructions and contract
procedure rules waivers
[Laughter]
yes it's our usual routine monitoring
reports and
actually great that rosie's here as well
for this one you don't often hear this
too so
um usual routine monitoring report just
to show you what waivers have gone
through since
since the last meeting in october
um and there's five waivers
and um given um bill's concerns earlier
um when a waiver is proposed it does go
through quite a vigorous
vetting procedure um so it's raised by
the officer
um given to their manager or strategic
manager
um to authorize um after it's actually
been to audit and
procurement for an opinion so if we look
at it and we
think it's not appropriate we will raise
objections at that point
um but quite often we're consulted on
them beforehand anyway so they don't
actually get to the waiver's station
because we've probably advised on them
um prior to that
so they are scrutinized um
by myself and and rosie um just to make
sure that
um a if it is claimed that the um
service is restricted to only one
supplier that's got to be
demonstrable and some evidence of that
that they have
tested the market and found that it's
only um restricted to one supplier
and also um if they are only using one
um to be very mined for the value for
money and and get some
way of com comparing if it's previous
work or
so forth to make sure that um it is
valued for money given the lack of
competition
um so so by the time they get to this
stage they have had quite a good looking
at
but i'm more than happy to take any
questions um
and and just to add i think what rosie
was saying as well under the contract
rules review um quite often we get
situations where
um a contractor is ideally placed to do
the work
because they've already implemented a
piece of infrastructure or
or something that they're familiar with
or they've already undertaken some
studies
that they have a lot of knowledge about
so to start afresh with a new contract
just would sometimes be
counterproductive and
that's quite often what we see with
these waivers as well
um that it's it's kind of restricted to
one contract
by virtue of their previous involvement
but again being mindful that it is still
value for money
yeah and i think i can see how i've seen
it the current climate
and contractors are incredibly busy and
sometimes you've just got to go with
what you've got at the moment otherwise
it doesn't happen
i'm looking in particular the um
construction of the walls at sherbourne
house to enable nhs occupation
um i'm really glad to see that that's
that's gone ahead um
and it's happening and you know things
like that we're quite happy to to
trust the officers to to get on with it
and get things like get projects like
that done
bill you've got your hand up yeah just
it's only just to say that
um it is one thing that i'm really
pleased that we do
look fully and investigate as fully as
possible
and i am obviously very much reassured
by what's been said at this moment in
time
but it is something that an audit
scrutiny um
team committee would in fact look at
because quite honestly it is something
that
um is something that we should look at
and i questioned it and i'm reassured by
what i've heard
so far so thanks very much for that yeah
i think it would be my chairman
sorry i was going to just kind of
question the green infrastructure
officer but you see that that funding is
provided by homes england it's
so we've got to take that when it comes
haven't we really um
chris sorry you're going to say
something yeah i'm obviously looking at
the
the first waiver there which is 35 000.
i'd just like to a little bit more
understanding of it
green communities project direct
appointment of dcc
transport contractor wsp to undertake an
active sustainable travel audit
and strategy for newt now but can you
just elaborate and tell me a bit about
this it seems a lot of money to
uh for this particular item what is a
sustainable travel audit and strategy
okay um i've got the full waiver here
um so so this follows um the other
reason for it is
that there had to be a review of
sustainable transport improvement needs
through a newt naba active and
sustainable travel audit and strategy
and some work on feasibility and
preliminary design and cost for
specific project work for the newton
albert garden communities bid
so tdc was awarded capacity funding
following a successful expression of
interest for the newtonia garden
communities
for use in 2019-20
and there are only a few months
remaining to utilize the funds
and complete all the documentation
required for the grant
um so we discussed the transport needs
with devon county council
and they were keen to take on the
responsibility for actually producing
the work
um but being guided by our delivery
requirements and a funding agreement so
that we could jointly oversee it
um but part of that work had to involve
a sustainable travel audit and strategy
for new snabbert
so devon county already had a contractor
wsp
who had skills and the knowledge and had
been tested via devon county selection
process so given that we were working
with devon county on this project
it just made sense to use them for it
given their closeness with devon and
prior knowledge of what we were looking
for um
but that was all from stemming from the
um newton
garden communities fund that we were
successful in being awarded
well i'm amazed to listen to all that i
see the amaze but
you know 35 000 it seems an awful lot of
money from
you know to do what you you've basically
tried to explain to me there but anyway
there we go i'm happy to give you more
info
after the meeting if that helps us
okay i'm happy with that i mean it's
clearly the funding that needed to be
to be claimed yeah yeah yeah
um script does anybody have any more
questions about uh
about this item
no um that's great i think
we've come to the end of our agenda
that's a
is that the shortest meeting we've had
so far um
let me see uh sorry i'm scrolling up and
down here
nope that's that's fine we're done um
thank you everybody um uh thank you very
much to the staff as well and thank you
for all you've done this year it's not
been the easiest year we've ever had and
i think the financial staff in
particular on the council have done
you know a really good job holding it
together
and it is very much appreciated and
noticed by us members who um you know
constantly furnished with the reports
and information and yes
you know managed managing to to do this
in in you know the state that we're in
at the moment and
it is very much appreciated thank you um
so all i can do is say um thank you
everybody have a really
safe christmas and a safe new year and
we'll have a meeting in january to do
with the notice of motion
and um hope to see you all back then
thank you very much
thank you take care thank you
congratulations gentlemen
on the shortest meeting
i finished school this morning i do a
school breakfast club i finished school
this morning so i really do feel like
school's out now it's great
yeah cheers all then yeah cheers merry
christmas
merry christmas he's safe
you too
thanks chris